okay we've got a david pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t I encourage you to join us there
more than 6,200 of our viewers and
listeners engaging in respectful
political debate they're few interesting
discussions from this morning one why do
you think the Democratic Party has moved
to the right I actually I'm not sure
that the Democratic Party has moved to
the right I think the Democratic Party
has not moved to the left at the same
speed as its constituents but the party
objectively I think has moved to the
left just very slowly like they came
around on minimum wage they came around
on on gay marriage they it's not that
the Democratic Party is more to the
right than it was years ago but it's
just not keeping up with its
constituents yeah I mean the Dixiecrats
are dead and gone you had a few of those
what do you call it Blue Dog Democrats
right left like Joe Manchin they're few
and far between then yeah I don't think
the party has moved right I think it's
just not keeping up with the leftward
move that we're seeing also from the
subreddit I'm apparently pronouncing
Natalia vessel needs Gaia incorrectly
it's a vessel needs Gaia and I'm not
apparently pronouncing that correctly
but you know sometimes you have to like
I think it's funnier to say sometimes
sometimes it's not it's it's funnier or
interesting to mispronounce things
deliberately and so I think I'm gonna
keep saying vessel and it's Chaya
because also everybody pronounces it
that way so if all of a sudden I say
vessel in its sky yeah you're going I'm
gonna start getting slammed for people
saying why are you saying that well by
that logic I'll start pronouncing Devon
Nunez his name Devon Nunez Nunez yeah
that's a good yeah I actually it occurs
to me I have weird thoughts like as I'm
drifting off to sleep sometimes and when
I had recently was what if with no
explanation we just start referring to
him as Donald Trump but we all we never
discuss it we just say Trump instead
Trump like the drum thing yeah I do
remember that but that's a little bit
you know off topic but but what I mean
is is it possible Pat that that would be
interesting in a way that I don't know
like what would happen I would get a
kick out of it would be like a little
inside joke that we can say Donald Trump
I don't know I I have these weird ideas
okay also from the David Pakman show
subreddit yes a picture
the commemorative Kim jong-un Donald
Trump summit coin with the title jumping
the gun perhaps yes those coins as I
joked earlier will be available for two
bucks on on either the the ground floor
of Trump Tower or maybe even on Canal
Street where you see a lot of this stuff
sold in Manhattan I feel like the price
on these would skyrocket because it's
never happened or novel now I I think
this thing is completely worthless and I
wouldn't pay more than a quarter for it
just as a complete novelty and lastly
from the david pakman show subreddit I
appeared on the creationist cat chat
channel where I was interviewed by a
very very religious I'd religiously
ideological cat and it's a pretty funny
thing you can check it out on
creationist cat chat I thought that it
was a funny interview a little longer
maybe then I would have gone if I were
running a cat interview channel right
but the follow-ups cats are good at
leading questions but not so good at
follow-up questions but I think you were
completely exposed in that interview on
the topics of communism Bernie Sanders
and fake news I'm surprised you're still
doing the show because I bad for you
it's just such an aggressive cat that I
thought it would be a total takedown
david pakman.com slash read it check it
out participate don't worry we have
moderators and you will not be trolled